je sais que vous accompagnez bien su peu
ce sgen genre ils ont besoin d'apprendre
ce qu'est la vie un jour ou l'autre ils
meurent très bien qu'ils se marient
là-bas dunkerque
alors regardez les enfants il n'y a
qu'une seule technique de drague c'est
la technique jean michel mr 40 secondes
top chrono
bonjour
[Musique]
le film a dit que vous appelez d'hadès
je suis désolé de dire vous importuner
mais si j'étais pas venu vous parler je
m'en serais voulu pendant plusieurs
semaines on voit là je suis désolé je
vous apporte une certaine mans voilà
j'avais envie qu'on discute un peu si ça
vous gêne pas trop vous déjà eu des
expériences souvent malheureuses parfois
heureuse où je tenais pas votre passé
mais je tape
en tout cas vous m'attire énormément
vous êtes déjà très belle je connais pas
donc je peux mal je m'arrête que
physique
mais voilà je suis désolé encore si je
peux vous laisser mon numéro si vous
avez la gentille
non